can machines be creative how long could
it be until machine composes a symphony
what even is creativity well hello and
welcome to the cheeky sign shape were in
this video we're going to be talking
about the book the creativity codes how
a eye is learning to write paint and
think so this book is written by Marcus
do so toy a British mathematician and as
evident from this book also an author so
I really enjoyed reading this book and
so there's a lot to cover and so I'll
mainly talk about the key take-home
messages that I got from reading the
book and some of the enjoyable parts
that I think you'll find entertaining
and honestly I did a white took me so
long to have to read a book about
creativity
like why went what's in silence at
school because as we'll find out
creativity is so fundamental to being a
human the book has definitely inspired
me and enabled me to embrace the
creativity that I possess so we'll begin
by addressing the big question which is
what actually is creativity and then
we'll go into the different chapters of
this book and look how artificial
intelligence is being used in art in
maths in music and also in languages so
there's lots of different cool things to
talk about in this video so yeah as
always hope you enjoy it so let's get
going so firstly why is Marcus a
mathematician taking us on this journey
into creativity and its overlap with
artificial intelligence
well artificial intelligence and machine
learning are based on algorithms and
codes and are all mathematical at heart
so in fact Marcus is a very good person
to take us on this journey and the book
begins with Ada Lovelace another English
mathematician who believes machines were
limited and that you couldn't get more
outs than you put in so the rest of the
book explores whether Ada Lovelace can
be proved wrong for what about
creativity as humans we have the ability
to create works of Arts that elevates
expands and transform what it means to
be human
these are the outpourings that marcus
describes as the human codes if a
machine was going to be creative it
would need an extra step
the
tribution should be more than just an
expression of the coders creativity or
that's the person who built the data set
so what actually is creativity well
there are three key components it has to
be something new surprising and that has
value well that's easy to say but how
easy is it actually creates creativity
well Margaret Baden a research professor
of cognitive science in the Department
of Informatics at the University of
Sussex he works in the fields of math
social intelligence
psychology and cognitive and computer
science has identified three different
types of human creativity
these are exploratory combination and
transformational so what is exploratory
creativity well Margaret describes it as
taking what is already there and
exploring its outer edges extending the
limits of what is possible while
remaining bound by the rules and this is
meant thought to account for around 97%
of human creativity combination
creativity on the other hand is how an
artist might take two completely
different constructs and seeks to
combine them together to create
something new but it is transformational
creativity that is more mysterious and
elusive is those rare moments that are
complete game changes such as Picasso
and cubism you might start by dropping
constraints and see what emerges the
arts the creative act is to choose what
to drop or bought fresh constraints adds
such that you end up with a new thing or
value so this idea of having to drop
constraints is kind of summarized very
well by what Picasso said the chief
enemy of creativity is good sense
so can you program in machine to behave
irrationally and can creativity be
taught well there's another element to
creativity that we've not yet spoken
about and that's history and historical
context plays a very important part and
allowing us to define something as
creative because creativity is not an
absolute measure but a relative activity
and so this includes acts of
no creativity that may be novel to us
but historically old news
it's like me making a risotto and
realizing but actually someone made it
you need that I don't know how long ago
bristle say I don't know 108 for
Christmas a terrible example anyway this
was also something that Margaret Braden
speak about and the idea that you have
the psychological and historical
creativity and so historical creativity
is emerged from encouraging
psychological creativity which are these
acts of personal creativity but if we
must get back to my risotto example
there is one important ingredient that I
need to be able to force the creativity
and that is to embrace failure is this
something that we can train machines to
do well we'll come back to that near the
end of the video but to begin with let's
meet stemis hassabis so demouth was a
child prodigy in chess and before he
even went to the University of Cambridge
for his undergraduate degree he began
designing computer games at bullfrog
productions and even Co designs the game
theme park which I definitely remember
playing as a kid's not as any good at it
but like bus is incredible anyway whilst
at Cambridge he learnt about the
artificial intelligence revolution and
became interested in what you can get
machines today in particular he was
interested in the game go a strategy
board game invented in China whereby the
aim assist around more territory than
the opponent now I've never actually
played going but it is very complex
compared to chess and so it was her
Sabbath's idea that's rather than trying
to write a program himself that could
play go he would write a meta program
that would be responsible for writing
the program that would play go the idea
that by getting a machine to play lots
of games of go it would be able to learn
from his mistakes and improve its
playing capacity and therefore improve
its chances of winning and learning from
mistakes is effectively what we do a
newborn baby does not have a brain that
is pre-programmed to keep with making
its way through life it is programmed
instead to learn as it interacts with
its environment so cyber's wanted to
know how the brain bugs therefore he
decided to
to a PhD in neuroscience at the
University College London with
discussions maids during this time his
PhD with a fellow neuroscientist and the
childhood friends in September 2010 was
the development of deep minds a company
that he probably now known as being a
Google owns company but the thing those
good minds needed money and picture got
a platform that they were going to play
games and self intelligence didn't sound
that serious but initially they did get
funding from Illamasqua and Peter Thiel
now before going straight to go they
tried their different algorithms and
methods at a more simpler game breakout
the aim of this game is to knock down
all all of the different boxes and one
of the most effective strategies is to
dig a tunnel but that's something that
you kind of learn after playing multiple
games and using this reinforcement
learning approach in this algorithm that
they generated the machine was able to
learn it incredibly fast now the next
challenge was go the program that deep
line eventually created was alphago and
they used alphago to compete against
well champion Lisa doe in a competition
that was set up in March 2016 before the
match started Lisa DOE had this to say I
have heard that deep minds AI is
surprisingly strong and getting stronger
but I am confident that I can win at
least this time I said this Ashley
Whitley reminded me of the omnijoin
and Incredibles that's when mr.
incredible beats that the first time it
learns from its previous mistakes and
comes back bigger and stronger
despite his words a confidence out of
five matches the final score was fall to
alpha gate once early but there are most
remarkable take him from these matches
was moved 32 of game T which was a move
by alpha game that has been deemed a
truly creative act an exploratory former
creativity because this move breaks the
previous got regards of how to play go
and now that they've seen this new
method it's revolutionized how people
play the game twin
it kind of demonstrates how artificial
intelligence is a tool for exploring
deeper further wider than before it is
not meant to replace human creativity
but augment it but why would you now
want to aspire to be the world champion
at go if you're gonna be beaten by a
machine now before we go any further we
need to talk about algorithms because
algorithms are key to artificial
intelligence now I'm not a mathematician
I'm a biochemist so don't worry we'll
keep this relatively simple but it's a
powerful reminder that our lives are
becoming increasingly pushed around by
algorithms that it's just so important
to try to understand how they work and
what they are doing because otherwise we
might be getting shafted so I've chosen
two fun examples that I quite enjoyed
from the book the first one is the
Google algorithm because who are the
magic Google elves scouring the internet
every time we make a search well there's
some quite case as we know are they fans
man didn't quite know that look into
that tweet if you want more details the
point is how did you come up with an
unbiased measure of an importance of a
website's such that the websites most
related to the question comes up first
in such lists now one way to do this
would be to look at connectivity between
different web sites and how they
interact with each other as a website
regarded with more links is more likely
to be trustworthy or more highly ranked
and so a mathematical tool that can be
used to look at this distribution are
matrices and you can develop mate
matrices of redistribution put the
precise parameters in this algorithm
actually kept secret and change over
time but the most remarkable thing is
how robust this algorithm actually is
but it isn't immune to clever attackers
and for a short period of time in the
summer of 2018 if you googled idiots the
first image that appeared was that of
Donald Trump
so I actually tried this out just the
other day and he still kept Donald Trump
as the first image another commonly used
algorithm can be described by what David
scale and Lloyd sharply described as the
stable marriage problem and this was the
problem as to how to pair up
for heterosexual men with women and too
much them up such that they have stable
marriages that means there shouldn't be
a man or a woman who would prefer to be
with one another than the partner that
they actually got in the example use in
the book we had the four kings and the
Four Queens found in a pack of cards and
they were tried to be paired up based on
their own preferences as to who they
wanted to get married to but the
interesting thing with this algorithm is
that there's an interesting asymmetry so
in the example given the queens proposed
to the Kings which meant that the the
Queen's got their preferred ranking over
the Kings because she actually end up
with a different stable pairing if the
Kings proposed the Queens and so this
has important implications because this
algorithm is can be used in fryi T of
different situations one of which was
used in medical students in America
looking for residences and the algorithm
that was being used previously
but such that the hospitals were doing
the proposing this meant the students
were getting the were still fortunately
this is now been reversed so that the
students are effectively doing the
proposing for the residences that they
want and so this goes back to the point
that it's so important to really
understand how these algorithms are
working but common to any algorithm is
the requirement for training data that
enables the machine to learn from what's
already available and to improve its
algorithm so then apply it to new data
and so this idea is that we need data
but you know we live in the day and age
now that's the amount of data produced
in two days is equivalent to the same
amount of data it took us from the dawn
of civilization and to 2003 to generate
and so data is now regarded as the knee
oil which is why you know companies like
Facebook Twitter Google and Amazon are
sitting pretty
we are pretty much giving them ourselves
for free well not entirely free because
we use their services but many people
are not aware of these transactions and
give up valuable data for little in
return now in the interest of time I've
skipped over the chapter talking about
advanced
and computer vision and far the
algorithmic evolution but if you are
interested and that let me know and I
can probably make a separate video just
talking about that but anyways now we're
gonna move on to whether or not machine
learning can be creative in terms of
learning how to paint to introduce this
chapter
Marcus begins with the painting black
4,900 Farben by Gerhard Richter which is
a painting composed of five times five
critter squares that have 25 different
colors and effectively by combining
these different wires in different
patterns there are 25 to the power of 25
different paintings that could be
generated and the question is why is
this regarded as art and not a book of G
Lux color samples both the springs
answer the question of what actually is
art and it seems less about the
aesthetic and skill and more about the
interesting message and perspective that
the artist is revealing about our
relationship to our worlds well this
seems like a free human ability so can
we ever regard artwork generated by AI
as arts and would you feel duped
if you cried as a piece of art if you
were later told that it was completed
generated now these are kind of
questions that there are yet new
distinct and clear answers to them but
there have definitely been advances in
terms of getting creative artworks from
machines and one effective algorithm
that has been used so far come under the
umbrella of general adversarial networks
and this is when you have kind of like
two algorithms one of which is tasked
with disrupting known styles of arts and
trying to create something novel
and the second one is tasked with
identifying the output as I've
recognizably arts which means that it's
not something novel or just
insufficiently original so you have a
generator and a discriminator and the
aim is to create things that fall into
the sweet spots on the one curve and so
this is a graph that shows that by
increasing novelty initially you see an
increase in the way
sieze which means that the effect is
pleasant until eventually it goes
negative and it becomes non pleasant
because it's too novel so our meds
el-gamal used a derivative of this
network which she turns creative
adversarial networks by by they
generated art by learning about styles
and deviating from style norms the work
that he created using his machine was
then presented at an art exhibition and
so this was shown at Art Basel in 2016
and so you can see some of the images
here some of them like actually looked
pretty impressive and while some of them
littlest were terrifying anyway what was
most interesting is that the some of the
few has found the arts more inspiring
and identified more closely with them
than some of the other art work presence
generated by humans but I think one of
the most interesting things that come
out from this book is appreciating how
we can potentially use the art produced
by artificial intelligence to try and
further understand the underlying
algorithm and how it's working so what
do I mean by this well a company called
deep dream that is a team at Google have
effectively developed an inverted
algorithm by giving the algorithm a
pixelated image and asking the algorithm
to dial up and enhanced features it
thought would trigger the actual
recognition of an identifiable feature
they could have an insight into the
facial recognition algorithms that
theatres algorithm is using turns out I
struggle to say algorithm
anyway tamarcus this is what art is all
about trying to understand the world
through a different set of eyes and to
connect with a different way of seeing
analogy would be why sometimes we see
faces and a piece of toast or animals
and clouds and so what Marcus explains
is that the human brain has a fold
sensitivity to images of animals since
it was key to our survival but what
about machine learning well what deep
dream uncovered is that apparently
starfish and ants seem to appear out of
nowhere but more interestingly it did
show how the algorithm had learned for
example images of dumbbells would always
have an arm attached to the dumbbell and
so it seemed that the way that the
algorithm had learnt was from images of
people lifting weights however sometimes
it was hard to name what the algorithm
was actually distinguishing in the image
and what deep dream say is that this is
more like penetrating the deep
unconscious of the algorithm and the
Google program is called this process
inception ISM and considered the images
to be like the dreams of the algorithm
so that was pretty cool but anyway our
inability to understand how algorithms
works is actually what's kind of fueling
the movies and kind of terrifying
stories about algorithmic apocalypse but
maybe by using these art forms it could
be an insights into how these algorithms
learning but art is just one art form
what about music now to quote Gottfried
Wilhelm Leibniz music is the pleasure
the human mind experiences from counting
without being aware that it is counting
and as a musician I can relate to this
quote but anyway it emphasizes how
actually music is very much an
algorithmic process and so it kind of
suggests that artificial intelligence
would be very good at generating bits of
music but are these bits of music you
know worth listening to or are they just
you know not very inventive because sure
music has mathematical elements but that
doesn't necessarily involve the
emotional connection that comes between
an artist and a listener and so the
example that I found most interesting
that Marcus talks about is about quantum
composing and this is the idea of
generating personalized music using data
from like smartphones and so what
quantum composing kind of refers to you
is about splitting up a piece of music
and kind of rearranging it in a way that
best suits the listener and so you end
up with a song that exists in many
different states like how in quantum
physics electrons can be in many places
at the same time due to quantum
superposition and so this approach was
used by the band's massive attack when
they released four new songs back in
2016 that you can actually access if you
download an app called phantom that
possesses this algorithm and does the
rejigging of the Micra tracks for what's
about song lyrics or more interestingly
what about books and novels in general
would you read a book written by
artificial intelligence now it turns out
that Rodo had this idea long before it
could actually be achieved and in one of
his books tells of the unexpected that
includes many different short stories
there is one titled the great automatic
Kermit a satyr a machine able to write
prize-winning novels but is merely a
crazy idea well in some surprise winning
at the moment most likely but let me
tell you about Botnick and machine
entertainment company that is run by
comedy writers and what they did is they
used an algorithm whereby they said it's
all of the Harry Potter novels and
generated some new clips of a potential
new Harry Potter novel some of the
passages are potentially possible such
as magic it was something that Harry
Potter thought was very Goods leathery
sheets of rain lashed at Harry's ghost
as he walks across the grounds to castle
for other ones were like absolute gems
ron was standing there and doing a
frenzied tap-dance
he saw Harry and immediately began to
eat Hermione's family
I'm sure JK Rowling would love that but
then Marcos drops the big bombshell that
actually 350 words of the book was
actually written by an algorithm and you
know I'm gonna have to say I didn't
actually notice but then 350 words is
hardly a novel so so far I've given you
pretty much a whirlwind tour through
this book but how can we summarize and
look at the key taking messages of the
book well one key take home is the idea
that all the decisions made by an artist
being driven at some level by an
algorithmic response of the body to the
world around it whether or not we
actually realize it and the fact that it
has this algorithmic basis does mean to
some extent it could also be encode Abul
by an algorithm but one really
interesting point that Marcus makes is
that our creativity is intimately bound
up with our freewill
you know we can live our lives like
Automator or we can suddenly make the
decision to break out of the routine and
create something that is new however to
program free will contradicts what free
will means or is free well just an
illusion of our underlying algorithmic
process now these all kind of big
philosophical questions to ask and there
are new clearances of movements however
currently we definitely seems a few
creativity as a human element is
something we do to kind of ass out that
we're not actually just machines and
indeed creativity is also tied up with
mortality it's about leaving something
behind that would actually outlast our
finest existence and therefore as
creativity a way that we use to cheat
death you know a machine isn't gonna
worry about dying or is it what if a
machine did become conscious how would
we ever knew whether it's consciousness
be anything like ours and so these are
the questions that Marquez asks right at
the end of the book and it comes back
kind of full circle because ultimately
it will be their paintings their novels
their creative outputs and even their
mathematics that will give us any chance
to kind of crack the machines code and
to feel what it's like to actually be a
machine so with that deep ending and
we're going to leave it here and just
say that yeah this looks pretty
interesting and I really have covered
very few examples that's covered in the
book so definitely check it out if
you're interested in learning more and
it's just yeah I don't even know what
else to say I just highly enjoyed it and
I think it's just really interesting to
try and see how this creative sides to
artificial intelligence because as Marco
says you know it's those algorithms are
being used in all aspects of life these
days
and trying to to understand the
algorithms to simple sense and if
creativity is one way in which we can do
that then yeah that's kind of cool and
yeah run out of things to say check out
the book if you're interested and hope
you've learnt something and as always
thanks for listening